I've heard from a bunch of you. David, did you sell out? David,
is the DNC telling you what to say? How could you do this to
us? >> Same person funding Midar's reporters and residence
program, which Taylor Loren herself is a part of. And guess what?
Her monthly stipend is $8,000 per month. Uh, I also was told
that other creators like a Twitch streamer named Hassan [__]
>> Uh, who David Pacman doesn't know at all. Okay, it does
look quite bad if she's doing the dark money angle, right? That
does look really bad when she's also taking dark money for like
the same
We just we find dark money interesting because obviously if you
don't know the source of the money, you don't know what their
goals are by giving you money, right? I find that like maybe
with this one it's less likely. Okay, these people are probably
most likely aligned with Democrats because it's BTC and he's
doing dem talking points. But in a lot of cases like with progressive
victory, I don't know that the people who were giving that money
had good intentions for Democrats. Okay, they uplifted some very
weird voices. They up uplifted some very controversial voices.
I don't think you can say that for 100%. Okay, I don't think
so. Okay, what's the latest? This is very similar to PV. whatever
they're doing here for this that's very similar to PV. PV is
not necessarily evil. But the my concern always comes from like
you don't know where the money's coming from. So you don't know
that it's like actually they could say they're doing stuff but
then they uplift like certain voices and they make you know leftists
they make Democrats look Yeah. Yeah. It's all weird. Okay. It's
all weird.
without further ado, let's get into it. I I asked Hutch this.
I was just like are you saying that she's lying about these contracts?
Also guys, engage with the blastoff tweet. Like the blast off
tweet. Engage with the blastoff tweet. Retweet the blastoff tweet,
which is this. I even put my my little broadcast there right
under it. Okay, you check it out. All right. What's up, full
of hell? How's it going, guys? We're going to get into it. Let's
get into it. Okay, so we we covered the article last night from
Taylor Loren. She just talks about Chorus. Basically, Chorus
was offering some smaller Tik Tok people, some smaller YouTube
streamers, you know, $1 to $8,000
to stream, attend meetings about talking points. Um, when a big
scandal would kick off or when some big uh when some big event
would happen in politics, apparently Brian Tyler Cohen would
go live to a meeting for all of these influencers and say, "Here's
what the messaging we want to push. Okay, here's our rapid response.
Here's the messaging we want to push. We want to be in lock step
on our messaging." All right. Uh, a part of these contracts to
get this money seems to be non-disclosure agreements and non-disparagement
clauses. Okay, you can't go after them. You can't go after politicians
without this company say so apparently. And you can't disclose
the partnership. This was like part of their rules. I don't know
if this is real. It was reported by Taylor Loren. It was reported
in Wired. I assume to put that article in Wired, Taylor had to
go through Wired's editors and give them like a well sourced
article. I don't think she could just make up, but it seems like
people are accusing her of making up. So, I'm gonna go through
some of these responses and we'll we'll see what gets said. Okay.
The first response that came out, >> all right, I going
to talk about this.
Pacman. David Pacman. Okay,
we got a response from David Pacman.
Let's check it out. Let's see what he has to say. They're trying
to take us down. They're trying to take us down >> cuz
I hate participating in >> 25 views in 5 hours. 25k views.
Yeah, some of his some of his videos pick up, some of his videos
don't. Pac-Man posts a lot of videos. So, you'll see this where
he'll have videos that just like totally fail and then videos
that do quite well, right? So, 41k in 2 hours, 65k in 3 hours,
24K in 5 hours, 153K. If it's got a Trump face in it and an arrow,
it's probably going to do good. If it doesn't have a Trump face
in it, it's probably not going to do good. No Trump face, 25K.
Okay. No Trump face 24K. Uh, let's see. No Trump face. No Trump
face. Uh, no Trump face 66K. Trump face 227. Not quite as clear.
Trump face 77. Okay.
It's It's very interesting. All right. Trump bad W. It's It is
what it is. Okay. It is what it is. It is what it is. We all
do what we need to to make money. All right. In the drama. I
hate
>> Let me uh let me get this turned up. David Pacman doesn't
want to be involved in the drama. It's whenever you want to trivialize
something that might matter, you just call it drama, by the way.
Okay. Hey, it's drama. It's just like uh
I was just a gooner, guys. It's just some drama. It's not a big
deal. It's not a big deal. Come on, guys. All right. I was not
even going to talk. >> By the way, just so you know, fbombs,
I see you in the chat right now. Just so you guys all know, I'm
not going to guaranteed automatically be against this. Okay?
I'm not against all dark money. Uh you could get me on a page
where I'm like okay with this. All right. I'm not principally
against dark money. I'm principally against it not being disclosed
that you're getting money from someplace. Okay. If these influencers
were saying were were getting talking points and they're involved
in some kind of broader scheme and they don't disclose that.
I am against that. But the dark money thing, I'm not I'm not
against it necessarily. I just don't like the I I really hate
the failure to disclose. Okay. talk about this because I hate
participating in the drama. I hate the circular firing squad
that often builds on the left. Uh but it's really important that
my audience know what's going on. So I am going to talk about
>> Yes. Soapbox that is what makes it dark money is they
do not have to disclose who the donors are as in
uh so the hypothetical with PV was if Peter Teal was the money
behind PV would you still feel like PV was working in Democrats
interests? What if Peter Teal was giving the money? What if a
foreign country was given the money? Right? By virtue of not
knowing where the money's coming from, I feel like you fail.
You you may not understand exactly what the interest of the group
is. No, no, no, no, no, no, no. Um, no, crystallize. This isn't
the case. Dark money isn't the failure to disclose on the part
on the part of the person who's receiving it. Dark money is not
knowing the source of the money.
right
now. There are some cases where, you know, if Russia was funding
people with my exact politics,
I don't know that I care or think it's bad that that's happening
if it's if I can't say it's coming from Russia, right? Like,
if a bunch of money is flowing into a cause I believe in deeply.
I don't know that I'm going to look at the source and care a
ton about the source, right? But I'd say as as an outsider, as
somebody who's not involved with that group, you might care.
You might think it's it looks weird, right? I'm not saying I'd
take Russia money. I'm just saying that like if I found out Russians
were paying for like um cancer research in my country that would
be weird to me but if it's a cause I believe in or something
that might not be I might not have like a huge issue with it
>> about it I was named in an article in Wired yesterday
and the article is about a so-called dark money group on the
left called chorus
and I'm named in the article along with other creators as being
part of the group and I didn't believe this part when we read
it that Pac-Man was taking $8,000 a month to like sign a contract.
I didn't believe it. That seemed completely unbelievable to me.
So, and since this article came out, I've heard from a bunch
of you. David, did you sell out? David, is the DNC telling you
what to say? How could you do this to us? I knew back in 2021
when you had the following to say that you must have been getting
paid by someone and here's the proof and I was not even going
to give this the time of day but my relationship with you my
actual audience is the most important thing and so I decided
to do this segment. Uh, I also was told that other creators like
a Twitch streamer named Hassan [__]
Uh, who David Pacman doesn't know at all. Okay. David Pacman's
totally not in a picture with Destiny, Molina, and Hassan [__]
smiling at the camera like they're best friends. Some dude named
Hassan [__] I think he actually just speaks this
way though when he's talking about third parties. I think he'll
pretend he'll he'll narrativize it like he doesn't know them.
recovering this in ways that don't reflect the reality of the
situation and are perpetuating falsehoods about what is and isn't
going on. Now, I can't speak to the motives
of the people that wrote the article or those that are reacting
to it. I can't get in their heads. All I can do is tell you what's
going on and then you can judge and you can make an assessment
of me. Now, I also want to mention I'm aware that many of the
people I'm hearing of aren't even part of my audience. They're
doing the well, now I'm unsubscribing and they mostly were never
subscribed. And so, I'm aware of that, but it doesn't matter
because I want to make sure my audience hears from me about this.
Now, the most important thing to say >> is bad. Son is
bad. Is bad. that the idea behind this group is exactly what
I've been advocating for for years. It's for years I've been
saying the left needs to organize independent media in the way
that the right has been doing. The left needs to fund independent
creators the way that the right does. The right has won even
arguably presidential elections because they're organized with
regard to online and independent media. >> I so
I would love to see the the evidence of this that there's this
level of organization that there's something like this,
right?
Because to be honest with you,
I see right-wing I see the right-wing political movement being
overtaken by populism and that that is being driven by like audience
capture and and a group who want to hear those talking points
more than vice versa. The Republican doing top down Republicans
doing top down control. The Democrats are proposing a way to
do top down control, right? Hey, we want Democratic aligned messaging
top down. What's happening with the Republicans is they are being
audience captured bottom up in a totally different way. And I
don't think I I would just love to see any proof of like this
top down control from Republicans. Like I I think the closest
you get is Trump taking people who criticize him and cutting
them off, right? That's that's the closest I can see this getting.
Was Trump going on Rogan from an organized group? I don't I don't
think so. No. Yeah. This is this is how I see it. Um, Porter
Beller, there's no dark money that is back in the Republican
movement. Is that what I said, Limbo Gaggins? Why would you totally
misconrue what I'm saying?
There's probably a ton of dark money all over the place. What
I'm telling you is it is not coming from a centralized place
for centralized talking points.
And I can I can tell you this because look at the Silicon Valley
billionaires who bought their way into the MAGA movement and
onto podcasts and to spew their talking points and they just
purely spent money to do it, right? Like nobody cared about the
things they were saying. Nobody gave a and then they just bought
their way in to this conversation and they co-opted a ton of
populist talking points to do it. A ton of populist rhetoric.
They built Ron DeSantis as a candidate to run against Trump in
the in the primary and he totally fell apart, right?
But but like they're they're trying to buy their way into that.
That to me is showing that it's not top down control from those
those big money interests. It's they're trying to figure out
how to tap into that and how to, you know, try to become the
the elephant rider. But they are by no means the elephant. They're
by no means actually controlling anything. And for me, what what
I see with the left is they want to do this top down control
where they're going to control everything. That can't work. I
don't think that works. Yes, this is exactly what I'm saying.
Gummy versus I think it's a I think it's an organic like audience
capture populist movement on the right.
Right. Way more. Now, there are groups who buy into that and
and twist that to their to their liking, right? All over the
place. But largely, we've seen the the corporate Republicans
get totally overrun by populist
Republican donors like the Koch brothers have gotten their lunch
taken, okay? They've gotten their lunch eaten by populist by
by populist by Trump and Trump's movement, right? They've had
to find a way to co-opt themselves into it. But it's it's like
the reverse that's happening. I I don't think I don't think you
can copy their ecosystem and do a top down thing where you're
like sending out messaging. That's not really what works. It's
like Republicans kind of flood the zone and figure out what works
with their audiences and then that's the messaging they amplify.
That's what it seems to be for me. Like way way way
>> The best the best you could say for it being controlled
is somebody like Peter Teal investing tons of money to make sure
Rumble's up and running and a place where Republicans can keep
talking when they're deplatformed. And then like that's that's
maybe what you could say, right? is Peter Teal did invest money
to make sure that Rumble existed, that Republicans could have
a place to make to make mo uh like their media to to put out
their talking points, but realistically they ended up getting
back into traditional media as well. So,
but I I'd say that's the closest you get to like a a top down
plan. >> Yes, we've been so behind and this kind of support
for creators is exactly what I've been advocating for. Now, the
article is riddled with inaccuracies, and they're not minor inaccuracies.
First and foremost,
this group has nothing to do with the DNC. People writing saying
the the the Democratic Party is telling people what to say. At
its base, the group has nothing to do with the DNC. Period. Number
two,
nothing to do with the DNC period. seems odd because I think
BTC talked about doing like like Democrat aligned messaging,
right? So, you could say it has nothing just it's a weird thing
to say we're doing this to align on Democratic messaging, but
it has nothing to do with the DNC, period.
I do not get clearance for anything I say. I do not run interview
questions by anyone at Chorus. I don't tell Chorus when I'm going
to be doing an interview. Not a single segment I have done, not
a single question I've ever asked a guest has anything to do
with chorus. They don't tell me what to talk about. They don't
tell me who to interview. They don't tell me how to cover a story.
There are no restrictions of any kind on my content. I've never
covered a story because Chorus suggested I do it. I've never
not covered a story because Chorus suggested I not do it. There
is no content relationship of any kind. So what does Chorus do?
They run technical trainings. How to produce content, how to
make your operation more efficient. How do you take a small shop
of one, two or three people and put content out on multiple platforms
the way I've been doing successfully for decades. They set up
mentorship relationships between larger creators like me and
small upandcoming creators who are looking to do content, which
is something I've said for years we need to be doing. They do
advocacy train. >> Okay, this all seems >> they do
media trainings. How do you deal with adversarial media
reporters with bad intentions who contact you? They do legal
trainings so we understand how is the right-wing machine potentially
going to come after us? How do you organize your business to
be protected? That's what they do. And I want to make this really
clear and I know that 99% of my actual audience knows this. If
this was a group or an organization that required me to get permission
before saying things or fed me talking points or told So this
is the issue is I don't think David would get the same contract
as everybody else. I don't think David would be told you can't
run your channel the way because they can't pay David enough
money to get editorial control of his channel, right? David probably
makes a serious amount of money from his channel. Like it just
doesn't work, right? The math doesn't make sense. You probably
have to pay him more than he makes from his channel, right? Cuz
he would be risking if he gave up editorial control of his channel,
he'd be risking like losing everything. You'd have to pay him
insane amounts of money to get that. So, I don't think anybody
would really accuse. And I I it did seem like they said David
was in the program where he had to sign the same contract, which
is bad reporting if he if he wasn't. But I've never really assumed
he would give up editorial control for $8,000 a month. That's
insane, right? But I do assume that for the smaller creators,
the really small Tik Tok streamers who they're getting into these
programs, I if they're being told you can't disclose this partnership
and we're just going to give you some money and you can't also
disparage like uh damn politicians, that would be concerning
to me. Okay.
So, David, I never really thought David was going to be a part
of much of this. I wonder if he can speak to any of those mechanics
at all or if he's just going to talk about himself. Me, David,
talk about this and not about that or anything like that. I would
never be part of it period. Anyone who knows me would know that.
Now, I'm one of the larger creators in the current cohort.
I want to help others grow. I want to mentor people. I want to
grow the left media space. That's something I've been advocating
for for years. And now the circular firing squad is getting going.
You look at tic tac. You look at these different platforms. People
that's I always get triggered by David cuz he does these things.
But I think he like memes on himself, right? That's him basically
calling himself a me like a boomer right there that he calls
a tic tac. I think that's like his he's just memeing on himself.
I'm I'm positive. Okay. There's no way he actually means that.
people going after each other. Most of it based on misunderstandings
or misreporting about what's happening. Now, let me go to another
aspect of this. I've seen messages like, "Oh, David, when you
said X in 2024,
that must have been because they told you to." Oh, David, this
explains your take on Bolivia from 2017. Now, I get why you said
that. when you did that interview
>> I'm pretty anti your current position. Limbo Gaggins,
can you describe my current position to me? The the position
that you feel like you're against. Can you explain your positive
case for how Pac-Man can do what he wants to do without leading
to current issues?
I don't even know what you're talking I don't know what your
question is, but I I don't It's interesting because I've like
basically said I don't like having things not disclosed. That's
like the only position I've given. So, if you're pretty anti
that position, that would seem odd to me that like disclosing
you're being paid by a certain group seems important. Anyway,
we could >> Maybe you weren't even referring to me. >> It
must have been because Chorus told you to.
Even if you wrongly believed that I was now completely compromised
by my participation in this group, this thing is brand new. It's
it's like 8 weeks old or something like that. Maybe 10 10 weeks
old, something like this. So the the revisionism of going back
and going now I understand why David not only are they not directing
content today this thing is brand new. So that's just like impossible.
One other thing I want to mention the article identifies
uh my friend Brian Tyler Cohen as the co-founder of this group
and now he's
>> uh 8 weeks will be the pilot program or the program
they're starting. I think Cherry, I think that's what the 8 weeks
would be like this new they said there's like a new cohort that
they're starting or something where they have new new um
oh where they have like new influencers coming in. I think that's
eight weeks obviously. I think Brian Tyler Cohen said he started
thinking about this or talking about it in November and he started
this sometime around November. Yeah, I I think David's talking
about something slightly different. >> Attacked as well,
his motives being impuged.
Brian worked on this as a volunteer. He has spent hundreds of
hours for not a penny on this project solely because he like
me believes
we need this type of organization on the left. They're killing
us on the right. >> He doesn't need to be doing this for
himself. He's trying to do this to build up leftwing content
creators as am I. And so the framing of Brian as some kind of
villain in this entire thing, it's just farcical empathetic.
So the bottom line is we need more of this on the left, not less.
We need more organization and infrastructure and people understanding
how do you build a content machine? How do you produce a podcast?
How do you grow an audience? How do you distribute it? How do
you organize your day? What's your YouTube setup like? The article
is designed to attack and degrade. I can't speak to the motives
of the people behind it. So, I won't even speculate. My involvement
is as I h I can speculate as to the motives behind it. I I know
exactly what the motives behind it are. Um,
but
it doesn't it it doesn't necessarily matter what their motives
are if some of it is accurate reporting, right? Like to me, the
thing that matters is are small creators who basically are just
trying to live long enough to to make their channels work, are
they being offered collabs and uh are they being offered collabs
and money in order to to say some of this this organization's
talking points and kind of hold fire left? Are they being offered
that? Okay, that would be concerning to me. And then being told
you can't disclose that you're taking talking points from us
or that you're taking money from us. That would be very concerning
to me. Um I'm not that concerned about Pac-Man. And what would
Pac-Man have to say? I don't think I honestly don't believe that
Pac-Man's taking enough money from these people that it's consequential
that he needs to say like, "Oh, I'm like I would say if you just
put something in your standard YouTube descriptions, right, with
all of this that says, "Hey, I'm a part of this chorus group.
Uh I I'm I'm paid by this chorus group." whatever. I think that
would be fine, right? You just put it in your stuff. The way
Lonerbox did it was when Lonerbox did paid promotion for Progressive
Victory, he had a playlist that was his progressive victory playlist.
He put things in his progressive victory playlist. He'd use um
he'd use graphics from them at the beginning of the video to
say this is a Progressive Victory sponsored video. I think that's
totally reasonable, right?
Is there any evidence that Zorg provided talking points or narratives?
Uh this is to do with um Brian Tyler Cohen saying that he leads
you know um oh what what's the language they use? I I think it's
like is it breaking moments or something along those lines. So
hold on Brian Tyler rapid response days. So this is reported
in the article that uh promoter co-ounded course with Democratic
influencer influencer Brian Tyler Cohen who is over 4.6 million
subs on YouTube and leads messaging check-ins for the content
cohort on rapid response days.
This would be yes sharing messaging for these days,
right? If a group is just because there's no way to know that
that's what's really happening, limbo gaggins, right? That is
that is doing like a um that's like that's like an implication.
Oh, you you have these talking points and then you have the money
coming in. Well, now you are in and you're being told, okay,
you can't even disclose this partnership. And it seemed like
there was some messages, some people in here were being asked
to sign contracts saying you can't criticize politicians without
clearing it with us, right? That would be really bad. But even
just the implication like you're just saying, oh, if they just
get money for being like Dems, isn't that fine?
That's what Tim P did is what Tim P did fine.
He was just he was just getting money and I fully believe that
there's no evidence Tim P was having his messaging controlled.
I don't think there's any evidence that he had his messaging
controlled. whatsoever.
He was just being paid because they liked how he was. Is that
fair? Is that fine? Do you think if Tim P like thought that Russia
might be paying him, do you think it's possible that he might
have tailored his messaging to that a little bit to make sure
he wasn't going to lose his payday? Like that's literally that's
literally all you have to ask is there's no proof that Tim Pool
changed anything. There's no proof that anybody had any editorial
control over him, but he was taking money from Russia. Why is
that a bad thing? Is this money from another country? You don't
know where this money is from. I'm telling you that it has to
be disclosed because you can never know like you you cannot say
that the money has no effect.
That's why it has to be disclosed, right? So there's there's
the example of so Wick TV is being paid $2,000 a month. Let's
say that's half of the money he makes doing streaming in general
is $2,000 $3,000 a month. Okay? He's being paid that by Progressive
Victory. a story comes up that involves another creator from
Progressive Victory who's paid more than him, who's a bigger
Progressive Victory creator. Does Wick feel completely comfortable
when half of his income is being paid by Progressive Victory
to go as hard as he's supposed to on that other creator in that
in that hypothetical? I don't know. And I think I think the disclosure
gives him a lot more comfort to go hard if he wants to or to
not like it just gives him more comfort, right? Should political
stream polit should political streamers disclose who is donating
to them through Streamlabs or any other sources to ensure they
aren't being paid by an organization? I think if you felt like
you were, but if you're being funded by like an organization
who's successfully covering that up and you just think you're
getting organic engagement, then I don't think you could. If
they know about it, they should disclose it. If they don't know
about it, then I don't know what they can do there, right? So,
like I hear this as like sort of a gotcha from the other direction
sometimes, and it doesn't make any sense to me. If you understand
it's happening, then yes. If you don't understand it's happening
then no JTO if he goes hard he could get paid more in fact I
don't yeah it's this could be another thing fbombs I think this
is less consequential to me because I don't think any of these
people cause any significant political change whatsoever so when
those people it's like
it's like five trees falling in the woods nobody heard it okay
I I just don't think it causes substantial political change that
might change at some point in the future with programs like this
right but the the panel thing I just don't I don't think Twitch
politics really makes a big difference. It hypothetically could.
It's probably an ethical violation. It's probably an ethical
breach. It's just one of those things that's like low grade to
me. I'm not sure I care. Monthly explanation of the biggest donators
public shaming of the Oilers in the country of origin. I I don't
know why that would be required. Um I you can't even get country
of origin from most donations,
right?
So I don't know how you would get that. You're just going to
go buy like dollars or something. I don't know. Doesn't really
make sense to me. It's like trying to muddy the waters. Usually
any any response like this is just trying to muddy the waters.
That the idea that it's like you have to go after the donators
or something. The individual donators. Isn't it against Twitch
to take pack money or something like that? I believe it is. Yes.
To do political advertising. I believe it's against Twitch to
disclose it, right? I think that's why there's a whole thing
there about why they weren't disclosing as well. Honestly, I
don't necessarily have a problem with this. I just want them
to say like, "Hey, I'm a Chorus sponsored creator." That's it.
That's
>> I've described it here. There's nothing more and there's
nothing left less. It's up to you to decide whether uh you trust
a particular creator. It's
if you have your DMs/ calls with your biggest Oilers, isn't that
as big a problem as this drama? Uh one, I'm not even like a serious
political content creator. Like I like politics. I would like
to do political content creation. Find that difficult to do on
kick. But if I if I was on YouTube, I'd probably be doing a lot
more politics content, right? soon will be happening soon. But
but
if I were a serious political content creator and I were to make
decisions or if if there was conflicts of interest, I'd have
to address that. I promise you there are major moderation conflicts
of interest that happen if anybody is paying me like $100 a month,
right? That like these people get away with like essentially
murder. That's that's just facts. Okay? You want to know you
want to know facts? You pay me $100 a month, you're you're able
to avoid moderation at the same way the same way most other people
get it. Okay. Yeah, that's a conflict. Yeah, I'm just going to
be honest about it. That's conflict. Clear conflict. Okay,
that's facts. Anyway, we >> It's up to you to decide what
sort of structural organization the left should
>> But what I can tell you is that the circular firing
squad is how the left loses when we start turning each other
over what at the end of the day. So what what I would love to
see here from David is just to say like um I would love to hear
his position on like the
in the article, right? Apparently it's alleged that there's contracts
being offered that prevent people from is bad that prevent people
from criticizing politicians and prevent them from disclosing
the partnership. If David could come out and say, "I think those
things would be really bad. I wouldn't want to be a part of an
organization, you know, holding that over creators heads, but
that's not what I believe the organization is, and I don't have
anything like that. And I believe this organization will correct
its wrongs and be better in the future." I'd be like 10 out of
10 statement, David. Fantastic stuff. Yeah, let's go, David.
Okay. But like this whole thing to just go, uh, guys, uh, Republicans
do this and like there's a fascist in the White House and the
circular firing squad is really embarrassing from leftists. That's
not tangibly addressing any issue at all. That's just that's
just going guys like what about Trump? Guys, what? Stop being
stop being like total lefties and and doing the circular firing
squad. Stop eating your own.
No, I mean there could be problems here, David. I addressing
those problems isn't even bad. And again, I'm not even I'm not
even going to say you can't take money from sources you don't
know. Go ahead and take the infinite money. Take the infinite
money. do whatever you want to do, right? But just say just say
that's what you're doing. That's fine, isn't it?
Isn't it?
You'd think so. I'd think so. Okay. We had um we had this this
lady over here. Okay. This uh who is this? This is um Oh, I should
get her name real quick. Elizabeth Booker Houston was somebody
mentioned in the article. Okay. Elizabeth.
So several influencers who doggedly defended course throughout
the contro that controversy including Elizabeth Booker Houston,
a Democratic comedian and content creator on Instagram and Alli
O'Brien, a progressive with more than 600,000 followers on Tik
Tok were involved in membership talks for the highest paid tier
in Chorus's new creator incubator program. Houston did not respond
to a request for comment. O'Brien declined a comment. So they're
saying that back when this first became a thing, I think back
in April, uh this Elizabeth Booker Houston person was defending
chorus. So, let's let's >> never cease to amaze me is the
way that a bunch of white women will revert to their default
settings and we're never going to get out of white supremacy
or fascism because of it. So, I woke up today to this article
in Wired that was sent to me by some folks that says that I'm
part of this creator cohort. >> I don't know how Taylor
Loren will never get out of uh
will never get out of this. Okay. Yeah. Taylor Loren, infamous
racist Taylor Loren. True. Getting >> dark money in the
form of $8,000 a month to push the Democratic party line and
keep a secret. I'm confused. >> Just to be clear, uh if
this wasn't obvious from the Kilo video on Progressive Victory,
dark money means the funding source is unknown, unttrackable,
and is unlimited. Essentially, that's dark money. Dark money
is not your disclosure.
Okay? It's dark money regardless of whether or not you disclose
it.
I'm not talking about it being dark on the creator side. I'm
talking about the source being dark. That is what dark money
is. Millionaires and billionaires are buying our political process.
Okay? They're spending millions of dollars every election cycle
and they are using super PACs. Super PACs to do this.
Citizens United must be overturned and we it will return to our
democracy. Okay? Like it's we all know where the talking points
are from. We've all heard them. Okay? We all know the crazy guy
with the white hair. That's the worst bit burning impression
ever. Well, I don't attempt it ever. I only attempt it when we're
talking about like super PACs or super PACs. It's basically super
PACs. Okay, tell me that wasn't Oh, shut up. That was obviously
Bernie. Shut up. Shut up. As I open the article, I see it mentions
Chorus. Now I'm even more confused. Chorus ain't no secret. I
mentioned months ago to my followers that me and some other creators
who are on the left were trying to work with um a PR firm to
figure out how to get funding to more progressive creators because
this [__] is hard. The right already has a ton of
funding. Under this fascist regime, it's going to be even harder.
We get death threats like that crazy MAGA dude trying to fight
me the other day. >> To be honest, does the right really
get like crazy funding? Like I don't know when did that start
that the right just gets like totally crazy funding from a bunch
of different sources cuz I actually don't know where that's to
me right-wing creators when I look at right-wing creators um
like the new ones, okay? When I look at somebody like uh like
Fuentes, Fuentes was grinding not making like any money for so
long, right? Like I see I see passion in the newer right-wing
creators. Bannon got six billion to start the right-wing machine.
I don't know. I don't know. Content creators sponsored by Bannon.
All All of those people feel fake to me. All of those people
feel like they're about to get overrun. They got that Peter Teal
money. Yeah, but the people who every time every time this happens
where like the big money comes in and tries to control things,
those people get spotted instantly and they'll be spotted way
faster on the right. Okay. Oh, sure. You're talking about TPUSA.
TPUSA is the big money. TPUSA is trying to control things. TPUSA
is about to be toppled. Yeah, TPUSA is probably like the actual
controlled opposition.
Yeah, I I I you know what? If we talk about TP USA, that's >> wrong
button. Wrong button.
Oh, we're going to watch uh we're going to watch some of this
Nick stream later, I think. >> Wrong button. Wrong button.
Uh where is it? Oi. Hey, Nicholasio has none of them principles,
mate. Willy M show. Yeah, I love JTO. Yeah, Cherry or something.
Yeah, do that. There we Is that what you That's not me. This
guy is uh
Wow.
I Why is he crashing out on us? What What the did we do? What
we did this to this guy? I love Jtock. Cherry, by the way, when
this all happened the first time with Willy Mack, I straight
up just asked very kindly. Okay, very kindly, "Hey, Nick, let's
have a conversation."
He still He still has never had a conversation. I didn't even
want to have a a debate. I don't want to have an argument. It's
just like a conversation. The guy's ego is so big. He like he
can't even It's It's just pointless. It's pointless. What a goof.
What a goof.
We'll uh We'll be covering this in just a little bit. Okay. We'll
be covering this. I I think he's mostly angry. Okay. He's mostly
angry that Willie Mack reporting Destiny to the cops didn't make
us all go, "Oh, yeah. Uh when you totally like maliciously lied
and spread Destiny's narrative to try to with us. We forgive
that." Totally. because you reported him to the cops now that
you basically had no choice, right?
Like I think that's what he's actually mad about is he wants
us to go and be like, "Oh, Willie Mack was cool all along." No,
this mother was lying. This mother just made some [__]
about us. No, it's not cool. No, he didn't apologize. Like, no.
Reporting Destiny to the cops does not make up for your lies,
for your job you did. That's not how this works, bro. Whatever.
It's fine. We'll we'll cover some of that later, I think. Let's
get through the chorus stuff. We're pretty close, guys. >> restaurant
like we get crazy us. So, like we need to get some kind of funding.
So, Chorus, I'm on the website. It's been linked in my bio for
I don't know how long. And I even did the DNT chair form with
Chorus. It's not a secret. But then they also said in the article
that they control my content and restrict it. Now I'm even more
lost cuz I'm like since when cuz >> so the I think what
I got out of the article was the smaller the creator you are,
the more it's just a take it or leave it contract. You can sign
up, but you have to agree not to not to uh what do you call it?
Like uh malign chorus or or talk about the partnership and you
have to agree not to go after politicians. And I assume that's
mostly just the smaller people. Can I get you to review the Destiny
post I made on Loader Box's subre? 200 plus replies at the moment.
I looked at it, Limbo. Uh I can I can go take a look if you want.
Um it's just going to be the same cope though. I don't mind taking
a look. I already know the one you're talking about and I don't
mind taking a look, but it is just going to be cope. Like obviously
cope. Uh,
okay. Taylor Loren just tweeted as well just recently. After
ignoring my repeated requests for comments prior to publication,
Chorus finally responded today. We've incorporated their comment
into the piece, but have not issued any corrections on our reporting.
The facts of the story remain unchanged. Now, it's possible,
guys, that Taylor Loren went to Wired and with no sourcing, with
no evidence, just was able to put this article out. I don't think
It's It's possible. I think that's like incredibly incredibly
unlikely, right? There's just there's almost no way that that's
possible. Okay, Limbo. We'll check this out after we finish the
chorus stuff. Okay. I wish I I should have downloaded this actually
cuz uh I would have wanted to pause and stop it. But uh this
person saying, "All I'm hearing here is I didn't get told that
I couldn't talk about it. I've been an open partner of this program."
And that's fine, but that's not the primary concern of the article
that some people who are who were there early on are disclosing
the partnership. The issue is small creators being offered money
to to not disclose the partnership to take talking points from
Brian Tyler Cohen on rapid response days, right? And listen,
I think a whole bunch of people, if Brian Tyler Cohen did like,
uh, you know, hey, some big scandal happens, he goes live, he
says, these are the talking points right here, and he just encouraged
people to like get behind him. I think it would have almost the
same effect and be totally fine, right? I think it would, but
that's not that's not necessarily what happened. And I I don't
know, man. Will you just keep watching? >> I ain't paying
for no content, and my content's been the same. I I I control
what I want to say and when I want to say it. And they're just
paying for us to be part of this training so we learn how to
use platforms better and grow on YouTube. Um we get to help each
other out, share tips and tricks, and they're paying us a stipen.
This is no different than any other professional training program
that pay >> This is different than every professional training
program that pays you a stipend.
I don't know. There's a there's a very famous saying, okay, very
famous saying, very old folksy, you know, saying that there's
no such thing as a free lunch. Okay, this is this is an an old
adage. It's as old as time itself. Okay, there's no such thing
as a free lunch. Nobody gives you something for nothing, right?
They think there's a tangible benefit to them in the long run.
That's why they're paying you,
right? I don't I don't know, guys. I don't change anything. There's
nothing going on. I just get paid to show up to some like optional
meetings once in a while for training and they're just all helping
me and, you know, I can just criticize them and it's all totally
fine. I don't think so. I just I kind of doubt it. I I feel like
that's almost certainly not true. Now,
I could see Brian Tyler Cohen being a part of something where
he wants to help out smaller influencers and he's going to set
some of his own money aside, right? If that's where most of the
money was coming from was BTC setting this up and he just wants
Democrats on the same page. So, he's going to handpick some people
and he's going to give the money to just keep doing what they're
doing. I could believe that. Okay. But when it's a when it's
a big political operation and they're offering contracts to people
and it's like basically trying to industrialize this process,
I do not believe for a second that they're just giving money
out and saying do whatever you want.
I'm sorry. I don't believe it that that's at scale what they're
going to be doing. >> PayPal to stipen so you can be better
at their jobs. It's really no different. So, we do this for 6
months. And then they also said in the article that they were
like controlling our access to lawmakers. That's not true. I
set up all my own interviews. You can go ask the lawmakers yourself.
I don't even know how cororus manage that, but they don't know
what I'm doing nine times out of 10 unless I choose to share
it in a chat and be like, "Oh, guess what cool thing I'm doing."
They don't have any control over it.
So, that was weird to me. And then to try to insinuate that like
they're restricting our content so we can't talk about certain
things. Like one of the creators mentioned in the same paragraph
as my name in this article, she was just laying into the Democrats
ass like not that long ago over the way that they are not handling
the genocide in Gaza correctly and how up it is how they've been
voting. Like she was laying into them, Cory Booker and all of
them. So I'm like, how the hell you going to That is an angle
I've seen people running with that I couldn't see any substantiation
for. Okay. Was that this was like Israeli money and they're being
told not to talk about uh Israel. I've seen that. I've seen that
angle laid out. I see no evidence for that whatsoever. I've yet
to see a single iota of evidence on along those lines. Okay,
I understand people want to run with that narrative that like
it's Israeli money and people are getting paid not to criticize.
I don't believe that to be the case. I've not seen any evidence
for that yet. If there's any evidence of that, I'd love to see
it, but I've seen zero. Okay. >> Going to say that when
you can go to the pages of the creators in the article and see
what we're talking about. >> That's weird. And I'm just
so lost because as a black woman who does political work already
there's a target on my back. >> This is already difficult.
I don't know why this person would like make up a bunch of stuff.
>> I don't I don't know. >> She also claimed that
I doggedly defended Chorus but then also said she never spoke
to me. I was not in the group chat mentioned.
But did you Hold on. Did you defend Chorus at some other point?
Why do people do this where like a point will be made and they'll
say something and it doesn't actually she's not saying this didn't
happen.
This Do you understand? You're not saying this didn't happen.
She claimed that I doggedly defended Chorus, but she never talked
to me.
Does Does she have to talk to you to like know whether or not
you defended them? I assume she means on one of your platforms.
I was not mentioned in the group chat mentioned.
I assume she's talking about anything else. Like
>> why? And it's really unsafe. It's not helpful. And it's
just flat out false. And then I found out that the journalist
who wrote it, she's in her own cohort of journalists and residents
with the Omidiar Network getting $8,000 a month
>> wait, but is she listed on their site? And is she is
it disclosing exactly what she's getting paid? Like I don't know
if Taylor Loren like let's look at this again. uh Spar and other
content creators have accused course of attempting to establish
themselves as a gatekeeper to democratic political leaders. What
we need is for people to invest in independent media and that
doesn't necessarily mean investing in a consulting group that
is going to become a middleman for independent media. Uh yeah,
sure.
So, I'm trying to look if there was another thing here where
there's a they're talking about like another
controversy. Anyway, it's it just says she's Elizabeth has has
defended this thing. uh were involved in membership talks for
the highest paid tier in the course in Chorus's new creator incubator
program. Houston did not respond to request for comment. I I
just I don't like I don't I'm not seeing anybody saying that
Taylor lied with any of this. They're saying I wasn't paid to
do this which is totally different. Neo Media Group that's one
of the people who has donated to 1630 fund. That's the same organization
that she highlights in the article that is helping us with our
nonprofit. It's the same.
So, I'm trying to figure out how that's like dark money for us,
but not for her. Like, I'm trying to figure >> uh if 1630
funds something that she's getting paid through, then that would
be dark money for her, too. I don't know that that's like the
main issue she has. I think the main issue in the article is
that it's not being disclosed with the smaller creators. >> Or
that there was a contract that had a non-disclosure agreement
in it. >> Okay, for her to be funded as a white woman journalist,
but I'm not allowed to get paid for my labor. And I'm I'm just
so confused. And this is really showing me that I don't care
if you are a white conservative liber. >> Let me hold on.
Let me just look again and see what she says at the end here.
Democrats don't feel comfortable with their lack of control.
Um she does put in quotes from these people at these universities
that basically say um hey it seems concerning that um dark money
on the right goes to people and and but is it ethical to match
the tactics of your opponent? So, it is kind of saying that it's
unethical to take dark money. And if Taylor Loren herself takes
dark money, that's an interesting play, I guess, for the article,
right? Uh, hooligans, I don't know why you're saying this is
crazy. >> I just clicked on something else.
>> One thing I will never see.
>> Uh,
hold on. Okay, we can go. I'm going to go over to Brian Tyler
Cohen's thing and we'll we'll cover the end of this video shortly.
Okay, it was she was just talking about how it was really tough
as a female black creator. Okay,
she was just talking about this, but we will go over to the Brian
Tyler Cohen thing in just a second. What is this? Mentally divine.
The true story behind Democratic influencers caught making 8K
a month. Democratic influencers for getting 8K a month. Okay,
hold on. This is another guy going and then we'll I want to do
the Brian Tyler Cohen response really quickly first. Okay, we'll
do that. BTC,
see what BTC has to say. >> Risk of giving. >> Okay,
five minute response from Brian Tyler Cohen. Some people have
questions about the creator scholarship program. I co-founded
Chorus, so let's talk about it. We are chorus.com. Stern them
up. >> At the risk of giving an internet troll more attention,
I want to address a piece that Taylor Loren wrote yesterday for
Wired. An initiative aimed at boosting Democrats online offers
influencers up to $8,000 a month to push the party line. All
they have to do is keep it secret and agree to restrictions on
their content. Literally nothing in this statement is true. The
article is about Chorus, which is a nonprofit that I helped found
to build up our >> Hold on. I got to I got to check something
out real quick. >> Career is his [__] The fact
that somebody could talk him into making a video on >> I
I did not talk him into making a video. That is also a complete
[__] lie. Another from Destiny. >> Off the
record information. >> Again, dude, I got to be honest
with you. There there is some charitability that I still have
for this guy, but all he does is lie about me. Like, what am
I supposed to think here? This is kind of an important thing
to be lying about
I feel It's career is >> all he does is lie about me. Like
what am I supposed to think here? This is kind of an important
thing to be lying about constantly.
>> I feel career. >> Sorry. Hold on. Back to BTC.
Sorry. I'm I'm tweeting. >> At the risk of giving an internet
troll more attention. >> Now I'm right. >> I want
to address a piece that Taylor Loren wrote yesterday for Wired.
An initiative aimed at boosting Democrats online offers influencers
up to $8,000 a month to push the party line. All they have to
do is keep it secret and agree to restrictions on their content.
Literally nothing in this statement is true. The article is about
Chorus, which is a nonprofit that I helped found to build up
our creator ecosystem, which everybody says they want, but few
are doing. So, here's what Chorus is. It is a scholarship program
to teach creators how to grow their accounts, foster engagement,
launch their own shows, and become profitable on their own. It's
an incubator program to build the prodemocracy ecosystem. Influencers
and creators have never been more important when it comes to
how Americans are consuming their news. The right has been doing
this for years and the left needs to catch up. That's why we're
doing this with Chorus. So, let's talk about what Chorus is and
what it's not. Chorus does not pay creators for content. Does
not tell them what to say. It does not control who they talk
to or work with. And there is >> Okay. I mean, he's saying
that it doesn't happen.
Do we take it serious? Do we take him serious here? boosting
Democrats online offers influencers up to eight. >> Also,
I'm I'm trying to craft this tweet in the right way. >> Thousand
a month to push the party line. All they have to do is keep it
secret and agree to restrictions on their content.
Literally nothing in this statement is true. The article is about
Chorus, which is a nonprofit that I helped found to build up
our creator ecosystem, which everybody says they want, but few
are doing. So, here's what Chorus is. It is a scholarship program
to teach creators how to grow their accounts, foster engagement,
launch their own shows, and become profitable on their own. It's
an incubator program to build the prodemocracy ecosystem. Influencers
and creators have never been more important when it comes to
how Americans are consuming their news. The right has been doing
this for years and the left needs to catch up. That's why we're
doing this with Chorus. So, let's talk about what Chorus is and
what it's not. Chorus does not pay creators for content. Does
not tell them what to say. It does not control who they talk
to or work with. And there is absolutely nothing in the contract
that
>> Why would you not take him serious? He's saying exactly
what you wanted Pac-Man to say. No, he's saying it didn't happen.
He's saying this doesn't happen. >> That could even be
reasonably interpreted to say that we do. Period. Full stop.
I don't know a single creator who would willfully sign up for
a program that would tell them what they can or can't say. That's
not what this program is. We pay people to show up to workshops
and tech I Okay, so very clearly all they have to do now
all they have to do now is um permission
raiders involved in the incubator program to share their contracts
publicly. Would Chorus
be willing to share the contracts
That would solve
this entire
solve everything. Solve everything. Yeah. be able to see. Uh,
I'm not going to put anything more. Yeah. Boom. There it is.
I just Yeah. If they're willing to share all that publicly, then
we're all good, right? Why doesn't the reported provide that
evidence? I would assume that they have examples of these contracts
or people talking about these contracts. They might not have
the contracts themselves and it a lot of these people might not
want to share those contracts, right?
I'm I all I think that happened here. So, so charitably what
could have happened here is also juice this tweets but um what
could have happened here charitably is there's some clause in
the contract that was misinterpreted by people right some clause
in the contract that people misinterpreted as like oh you can't
actually talk to politicians you can't actually criticize politicians
that you can't actually do certain things right and if it was
just a misinterpretation that people had they took it to a chat
and then Taylor reported on those chats and and their Then I
don't think anybody's doing something malicious here. And you
can just clear this up entirely by posting the tweets or sorry
by posting contracts. That's all you got to do, >> There's
influencers up to 8. >> Uh whoops. These are This is where
we're on. Uh Nope.
Oh, I tweeted about it. >> Not tell them what to say. It
does not control who they talk to or work with. And there is
absolutely nothing in the contract that could even be >> Wait,
did they give an example of someone coming forward saying this
is in their contract? Yes, Twisted Rope. Did you not read the
article? Do you not know what we're talking about? That's the
whole point of the article, right?
According to copies of the contract viewed by Wired that creators
signed, the influencers are not the influencers are not allowed
to disclose the relationship with Chorus or the 1630 fund or
functionally that they're being paid at all.
Right?
That's that's the big criticism.
If this is if this is being said and it's it's false, then just
post, right?
Who did they use as an example? They didn't use they they said
Wired as in viewed by Wired. That to me means viewed by Wired
means
Wired's editors looked at this as well as Taylor did. Wired is
not going to let Taylor Loren write in an article that Wired
viewed these contracts unless a Wired editor looked at these
contracts with her. It's interesting that they aren't publishing
it. Wait, why is it interesting that they aren't publishing it?
I think there's every reason to think that they might that that
could like like it might have been shared under the agreement
that they don't publish it, right? Yeah, exactly. It could it
could actually like torch this person um and and their relationships,
right? And I I actually believe Brian that like he he doesn't
think this is in here. The allegation is that contracts
offered to these smaller influencers
prevented them disclosing the partnership. That is that is they
can and can't say this is a lie. Then it appears
Wired's
editors and Taylor Loren's are both complicit. That would be
telling them what they can and can't
Appears Wyard's editors and Taylor Ren are both complicit. Yes.
Okay, that's about what I want to say there. Cool.
interpreted to say that we do. Period. Full stop. I don't know
a single creator who would willfully sign up for a program that
would tell them what they can or can't say. That's not what this
program is. We pay people to show up to workshops and technical
trainings to optimize their content online. For example, we've
got trainings on how to package content for YouTube, trainings
on how to optimize audience retention for Instagram and Tik Tok,
trainings on how to form an LLC. Again, there are zero restrictions
on their content. And by the way, the program works. In just
two months, our cohort has added a combined 6 million followers.
That's not including me, and seen their views and engagement
grow. That is the point of the program, to teach creators how
to be effective with whatever messages they want to promote.
Wired being willing to hire/ost Taylor's article is proof enough
that for me that truth isn't their priority.
Uh, Taylor has like some Taylor has like some pedigree as a journalist.
I think she's wildly biased, right? I think that this article
is mostly made because Hassan is sort of being cut out by these
same people. She's sympathetic to Hassan and the progressive
movement. She feels like Hassan as the big as one of the biggest
progressive influencers is being cut out. She's I I think that's
a ton of why she would be posting this article. But the facts
in the article remain the facts of the article, right? There
are things to complain about there in terms of disclosures. And
to me it seems like, okay, it feels like Democrats do this kind
of thing and then it gets out and and then the stuff changes.
Like with Progressive Victory, when all the stuff about Progressive
Victory came out, they changed their entire structure. They changed
entirely how they paid people, right? So to me that seems like
that to me seems like, oh, this is something that's like probably
illegal and or gray area enough that these people want to like
reorganize everything when it gets pointed out. I think so. Taylor
will editorialize. I don't know where she's like lied. She'll
editorialize, right? I don't know where she's outright lied in
a piece that is like not an opinion piece. If you can show me
some evidence of that. I think Taylor Ren sucks and I think her
journalistic like integrity is bad. But I don't think she outright
lies cuz most journalists know if you get caught like outright
fabricating things, you'll be in trouble. What has changed here
since the article came out? What do you I don't even know what
the question is, Nick. I don't think any the article came out
yesterday. I don't know what could have changed >> promote.
And with regard to keeping it a secret, there is a standard confidentiality
clause in the contract to protect the privacy of the creators.
On the literal first day of the program, it was made clear to
all of the creators in our kickoff session that they were absolutely
free to talk about Chorus. And we immediately followed up to
confirm that in writing. Creators have videos about Chorus. They've
got donation links to Chorus in their bios. I myself have made
videos that were posted all over the internet about Chorus that
reached hundreds of thousands of people. It is not a secret and
it never was.
So here again, I I get the impression
that Brian is not lying here that he feels like some people thought
it meant don't disclose the funding and that he got writing out
or they got writing out to say otherwise. Yeah. So So that would
be I feel like he's not lying and and maybe this is a misunderstanding
or something they didn't really want to say, right? Why does
he show this in writing? Yeah. I was just saying if you showed
in writing like I would love to see what was put out in writing.
Right. Because it's possible that um it's possible that
you said PV changed after it came out. They were paying creators.
Has this group changed anything? It's too soon. It's just too
soon. Um
[__] I don't know why I just read chat. I need I
need to lock in on like Brian Tyler Cohen's face right now to
to not get [__] I don't think he's lying here. I
think it's entirely possible they didn't want this. That it was
some some legal boiler plate that got put into the contract.
They don't actually care about it, right? And it's a misunderstanding.
They reported on old facts. To me, then it's pretty easy when
Taylor Loren says, "Hey, I'm producing an article. Would you
guys care to comment?" I don't know why they didn't comment,
right? That seems very confusing to me that you wouldn't go,
"Oh, that's actually a total misunderstanding. Could you clear
this up? Here's like our writing. Here's the writing we put out
to creators when that misunderstanding came up and we cleared
it up and we actually fixed this." Right? There's the implication
in the article that this is some arm of the DNC or the Democratic
Party. We have literally nothing to do with the DNC. I spend
zero minutes of my day thinking about the DNC. The creators do
not tow any party line. How could we? There isn't a party line.
Creators are absolutely allowed to speak. I'm trying to You're
trying to create the party line. I I understand why he's going
to play Koi here, but I I think he's actively attempting to create
what the party line will be.
He's playing Koi, but it's it's I Man, I think you're just trying
to create it. like there isn't a party line because the party
line you you feel like the party has never been good at saying
what the line is. I think you're trying to create the party line.
Speak out against the Democrats and in fact plenty do and frankly
chorus creators should and do criticize Democrats when they suck
and quite often they do suck. I've seen posts saying that uh
this is Apacfunded which couldn't be further from the truth.
I'd venture to guess that most course creators, myself included,
on both YouTube and Substack, have spoken out against the atrocities
in Gaza. Loren says that the 1630 fund is quote a powerful liberal
dark money group. 1630 Fund is our fiscal sponsor. One of the
largest documented donors to 1630 fund is the same person funding's
reporters and residence program, which Taylor Loren herself is
a part of. And guess what? Her monthly stipend is $8,000 per
month. So, she's
It does look quite bad if she's doing the dark money angle, right?
That does look really bad when she's also taking dark money from
like the same group. I think I think that's pretty obvious, right?
That that looks super bad when you're when you're putting in
there, you're leaving the implication in that dark money is bad.
You're taking dark money from the same group. That's pretty nuts,
right? But we already called that out because I think uh somebody
else I think Elizabeth said this, right? In Elizabeth's video,
we had this. So, we we knew that already. That looks pretty stupid.
Uh, that's not something I'm going to necessarily say you can't
do. Okay, I'm not going to say you can't take dark money. Um,
if that's the name of the game, I understand that there's some
some requirement there. And I I think if you're going to take
dark money, it's actually probably better that you have a middleman
like this that is directing that money so that you have somebody
with a face there that you can trust is going to direct the money
in the correct way. That the money is basically coming in without
strings and they're going to direct that money in a in in a way
that you approve of. If it's just like dark money that's coming
in and you don't really know the people in charge of it and it's
going out, that feels concerning, right? This feels like about
the best way you could do it if it's all done above board and
there aren't there aren't like non-disclosure agreements that
prevent people from uh disclosing that they're being paid. Is
criticizing an entity that is funded by someone that she is currently
taking money from. I guess it's okay when Taylor Loren gets paid,
but no one else. The monthly stipen that we offer is so that
creators can do this work full-time. We've had numerous creators
in the cohort quit their job so that they can focus on creating
content full-time. That is what we want. I'm really proud that
we can give creators that security for as long as they're in
the program. We want people to create pro-democracy content full-time.
And we want to make sure that they can afford to pay their rent
and their bills while doing it. If I could have cohorts with
a thousand people in it so that everybody could be part of the
program, I would. For everybody saying that they would like to
be part of the next cohort, we would love for you to apply. That's
our whole goal. It's to build up an army of pro-democracy content
creators who can speak authentically about the issues that they
care about and be able to do it as effectively as possible. I
should note that while I started So this is the thing one toker
I I do agree with that and I'm fine I'm okay with dark money
coming in the way it happened with PV where it wasn't being disclosed
at all and Pavey's original decision-m with that money was super
suspicious. Okay, they paid some of the like worst people to
be like standard bearers for the Democratic party and is it was
insane. Okay, I think that looked really weird. And then the
second iteration wasn't a whole lot better. It was Brianna Woo
instead of Imagine you have an organization. You could pick Bryant
Tyler Cohen, guy who's incredibly put together, who's got all
of his down, right? Who gets a ton of done or Briana Woo? Brianna
Woo at the head of it. Yeah, of course that is going to crash.
Okay, of course that shit's going to fall apart. BTC at the head
of it. Okay, that's a little better. Okay, hold on. And I've
been uh sorry I'm tweeting in the background here as well. >> This
program I have never and will never get background. I do this
100% as a volunteer. I have never earned a dime from chorus and
I never will. I want every dollar that we raise to go to creators
so that they can do this important work without spending 8 hours
a day working at some different job. I've been saying for years
that the left needs to build up its creator space. That has never
been more true than it is right now. Influencers and creators
have never been more important when it comes to how Americans
are consuming their news. The left is a decade behind right now.
We desperately need incubators teaching and amplifying new content
creators and not just chorus. By the way, there are other programs
in the space doing the same thing. I want all of them to succeed.
We need all of them to succeed. There are people like Taylor
Loren who are desperate to tear the left apart. And in fact,
it becomes clear who her efforts help when you hear stuff like
this. >> Genuinely, I kind of like Taylor Lauren because
I know that she actually believes what she says. Do you get what
I'm saying? >> So, yeah. I uh generally don't align myself
with friends of Tucker Carlson and Candace Owens. I continue
to believe that the left needs massive investments into the independent
media space. I'm really proud of the program that we've built.
I'm really proud that we've allowed creators to do this work
full-time. I'm really proud of the independence that they have
to say and I don't necessarily think this is like uh I don't
know, man. I don't know, man.
I think
if he just if he just posted a contract, he's saying that like
hey, we cleared this up that people thought this was a problem.
We cleared it up. Now, I would wonder why he didn't leave a comment
on the video. Okay.
Or sorry, on the article. Why they didn't make a comment on the
article. They they didn't like clear it up before the article
went out. Maybe Taylor did not actually give them any Maybe Taylor
didn't actually give them uh enough time to respond or something.
>> That they have to say whatever they want to say in whatever
way they want to say it. I'm really proud that our creators are
seeing their channels and their pages grow. My goal is to see
an army emerge from the left to take on what's happening on the
right. Taylor Loren and Republicans don't want to see it, but
we do. If you also want to get in the fight, apply to the program
at we chorus.org.
We are chorus.com or.org.
>> Which one? Brian. Brian, which one? You should apply.
No, I'm good. Uh, I'm good. Okay.